what did Queen Elizabeth mean to the
Jewish Community well first of all we
just loved and admired her and the grief
is enormous this is an exceptionally
Saturday for Britain for the
Commonwealth and for the world we took
enormous pride in our wonderful Monarch
and at the same time we deeply
appreciated the extent to which she
reached out to all faiths she was a
champion of the right of all faiths to
thrive and to practice their religious
identity and freedom
what are your memories of meeting her oh
I met on many occasions and
exceptionally lovely Charming warm
person you know many people comment on
what the queen said to them I'd like to
highlight the extent to which she
listened to people she was a good
listener and she remembered what people
said and would come back to you after a
while and remind you of things that she
had heard being said
she genuinely cared about all people and
I believe that's actually the reason for
the Deep grief at this time she didn't
just have impressive titles she was a
genuine person who loved everybody and
that's why we all loved her I spoke to
the Archbishop of Canterbury
um at the end of last week and he was
talking about how
um those that are are grieving uh are
finding it but perhaps not just for her
majesty but also for grief that they may
have suffered in their own lives what
advice are you offering to people of
your faith
the important thing is talk
if we speak about grief then it's easier
if we grieve collectively then it is
easier and that's certainly what is
happening now so impressively right
around the world and I would add
something today something extraordinary
is going to happen in just a few hours
time we're going to have an
unprecedented number of world leaders in
one place at one time a wonderful sense
of warmth of unity and of Harmony
I think we shouldn't only concentrate on
today let's concentrate on tomorrow why
can't we keep that sense of unity and
Harmony I believe the ultimate tribute
to the legacy of her majesty the queen
will be if in her memory we guarantee
that we now will have a harmonious in
United Society
talk to me about Westminster Abbey we'll
be there later what will that mean to
you
well it will be a great privilege for me
to represent the Jewish communities of
the UK and the Commonwealth alongside so
many notable people I think we'll be
concentrating on her majesty the queen
what a sad moment this will be and will
be United in our grief
I'm guessing you've met King Charles
when he was the prince of Wales what are
you expecting from him in his Reign I
know for certain that he will continue
as King Charles to do exactly what he
was doing as Prince Charles and I had a
lovely reflection of this on Friday when
he received Faith leaders in Buckingham
Palace and I was honored to greet him
and to convey our condolences to him and
that meeting was scheduled to be just
before our Sabbath which meant that I
wouldn't have been able to attend I
wouldn't have been able to get home for
the Sabbath but the palace brought the
meeting earlier and King Charles was
absolutely insistent that I should leave
as quickly as possible in order to get
home for the Sabbath he genuinely cares
about other faiths and please God he'll
be a great Monarch looking at people
arriving at Westminster Hall that this
is likely to happen over the next couple
of hours or so ahead Westminster Abbey I
should say of course um the queen
um still that we can see there at Nadeem
Sahari representing the government who
who has been very much involved with the
Cobra meetings throughout the last few
days putting together events my goodness
me how difficult it must have been to
organize
it's unbelievable what has been put
together in a matter of just a few days
in our community we had that experience
because we staged a memorial service for
her majesty the queen last Wednesday
evening and it was as if we had clicked
our fingers and suddenly thousands of
people on Zoom a wonderful attendance at
synagogue and that's what's happened all
around us
yeah indeed so um some 2 000 people
can attend at Westminster Abbey um Her
Majesty will eventually be laid to rest
at St George's Chapel at her beloved
Windsor she very much enjoyed being
outside of the Capitol she saw
Buckingham Palace very much as her
office I believe in in later years
um
for those that are finding it almost
impossible to comprehend that the one
constant in their life throughout their
lives has now gone
what what words of guidance are you
offering
well I think that we should cherish our
fond memories her Legacy is enormous
King Charles will certainly help us
through this path in the pastry
Elizabeth and era and it's so important
for us not just to remember her
qualities and her values but for them to
be reflected through us in the future
she was an exceptional person unlikely
that we will come across such a person
ever again in our lifetimes so let's pay
honor to her by being just like her
and this Caroline era that we have now
entered
that will cannot be the same as the
Elizabethan era was it will have to
change
yes oh absolutely you know the the best
advice I can give to somebody who is
stepping into big shoes is that you
should buy a new pair for himself and
that's certainly what I think King
Charles will do he will continue in the
footsteps of his revered and much loved
mother but at the same time I think he
will stamp his personal Authority and
reflection on his Reign and please God
it too will be a wonderful era for all
of us